j'ai travaillé en tant qu ingénieur
électronique parisot informatique et
communications en français
russe un petit peu distant et je me suis
rendu compte que quatre couples de la
publicité
les solutions existantes étaient soit le
groupe lettres j'aime la lampe de poche
et parfois des bougies d'absolution
était beaucoup plus onéreuse un mot
l'idée m'est venue en disant qu'il
fallait trouver une solution alternative
est un à la fois autonome et permettant
d'être éclairé sur un long terme à
quatre coupes et de laïcité
no comment se présente votre système son
assistant qui se connecte directement
sur le contrôle strict et à l'aide d'une
batterie
il permet d'alimenter ou de noble idée
une bnf 4,2 de 24 heures à plusieurs
jours en fonction de son utilisation par
une copine alors votre votre invention a
été breveté par l'inpi vous avez aussi
eu la publication internationale à
l'organisation mondiale de la propriété
intellectuelle
à la date d'aujourd'hui
qu'en est il exactement alors 2016 j'ai
obtenu les certifications européennes et
au hsc mcvd ça concerne les normes sur
la compatibilité électromagnétique sur
les produits chimiques capa vous
diffuser uniquement en cas de fait par
exemple
aussi la libre circulation d'une équipe
mancelle et comment avez vous fait pour
obtenir ces certifications
il ya eu un passage du zinnia une
fabrication
le principe est de fabriquer
l'équipement en 331 il ya un organisme
international qui le dit quantique qui
est des cantiques choc et des composants
y compris le boîtier les boulons des
composants électroniques qui font dans
la liste précise la composition chimique
des cantiques après qu'ils font des
tests électriques en fonction de la
situation et qu'ils vérifient les
émissions électromagnétiques rayons
gamma est au bout de certains tests